all right returning now to our top story
and that breaking news out of South
Africa at least 63 people killed and 43
injured after a fire broke out at a
five-story building in the early hours
of Thursday morning in Johannesburg
let's bring in our correspondent famita
Miller who joins us from the scene of
that fire what more are you finding out
from either about the circumstances of
this place
but hopefully that death toll does keep
changing um almost minute by minute and
it's now 64 people that have been killed
in that fire that broke out in the early
hours of Thursday morning but I'm going
to bring in emergency services Robert
malozi to explain to us what's happened
and what they've done to put that fire
out and rescue as many people as
possible but Robert we do understand
that at this stage it is now a search
and Recovery the fire has been
extinguished but you've also described
it as one of the worst you've seen yeah
so as I said they did in the city of
Johannesburg you know losing about 64
lives and still counting is a very
sadding day indeed it's something that
it will take some time to happen again
you know so we right now we've got a
responsibility to make sure that we
recover all the bodies which myself be
trapped inside the building floor by
floor that's what we're doing after that
we will be handing over the incident to
the South African Police Service to
continue with their investigations so
far about 43 people were treated for
minor injuries
they were treated for smoke inhalation
and they were later on transported to
various Healthcare facilities for
further Medical Care
what led to the fire I know you've said
the investigations are being carried out
but there is a very high death toll
what's contributed to that no we we at
this stage we don't know what might be
the cause of the fire but looking at the
environment inside is an informal
settlement inside the building so
therefore the risk of people being
trapped inside is very much high and you
find that we've got a lot of fatalities
in this incident now in South Africa we
consider this to be an abandoned
building and then a hijack
apologies we have lost our connection to
our correspondent femita Miller there
who was reporting from the scene of that
fire in Johannesburg she's back with us
because the services which are mostly
rendered by the city they don't pay for
those services
I would see they're just explaining
outing he's described it as an informal
settlement and that's because hundreds
of people live in what was an abandoned
building abandoned by the original owner
and then taken over informally and
people renting space in that building
and so safety regulations weren't in
place authorities here City officials
are uncertain as to how the fire started
but they do know that 64 people have
been killed and it's likely they may
find more bodies as they continue the
search and Recovery operations in that
building famida thank you very much for
the moment of course we will be checking
in with you for further updates on this
fire in Johannesburg South Africa which
has killed at least 63 people the death
told us amida was saying continues to
rise